let's talk about uh we got this story
from the new york post jen seki breaks
down while discussing harsh and cruel
cruel lgbtq legislation wow sounds mean
sounds like there's some mean laws here
we go white house press secretary jen
sackey began sobbing during an interview
this week as she talked about a spate of
bills that critics say are targeting gay
and transgender children claiming that
kids are being used as weapons in a
political culture war zaki was asked
during the interview with news not noise
podcast about legislation like florida's
so-called don't say gay bill which
prohibits the discussion of sexual
orientation or gender identity in
kindergarten through third grade as well
as instruction on those topics and in a
place in manner that's not
age-appropriate
quote this is a political wedge issue in
an attempt to win a culture war sekki
said as she began audibly weeping
and they're doing that in a way that is
harsh and cruel to a community of kids
i'm going to get emotional about this
issue because it's horrible but it's
like kids who are bullied and all these
leaders are taking steps to hurt them
and hurt their lives and hurt their
families and you look at some of these
laws in these states and it's going
after parents who are in loving
relationships who have kids it's
completely outrageous sorry this is an
issue that makes me completely crazy
jensaki is a sociopath i don't want
completely crazy people in government
she admitted it not going to get it so
first of all the new york post should
not be calling it lgbtq legislation
new york post mark moore
you should correct this because the
parental rights and education has more
to do with parents having access to
information about the schools and gender
identity and orientation is also about
being straight it's just
orientation which could be straight or
not in which case it is just legislation
on sex ed and it's not even that it's
the parental rights and education bill
so get that right gensequi knows this
they look
we are well past the point where i'm
going to assume genseki doesn't know
what about what this bill is
she's crying crocodile tears to
manipulate people because liberals are
people who according jonathan heights
research
are more interested in care and fairness
more emotional aspects as opposed to
sanctity purity authority loyalty etc
liberty
so when you approach a conservative and
they have six moral foundations there is
authority authority and loyalty there is
sanctity purity things like that and you
say
dryly and as matter-of-factly they're
going to say okay
the left needs to win by making you cry
by crying and begging for care begging
for sympathy so when jen starts crying
she wants people to go oh jenna yo it's
so it's so oh well it's so embarrassing
i mean i remember after but it works
freaking nice
one thing that i saw after the 2016
election that really struck me was the
fact that they were posting pictures of
themselves crying and i thought how can
you have such little dignity that you
think that's a good look i i i would be
mortified first if i cried over an
election and i was sitting there bawling
my eyes out you can believe i wouldn't
be posting pictures of it on the
internet the next day as if that was a
good look for me as we're talking about
it i'm thinking hitler's girlfriend
probably cried when he killed himself
like yeah crying emotional doesn't mean
you're right people get emotional about
evil if they're on the side of evil so
yeah this girl totally lost it yeah i've
watched murderers cry and you in videos
like they're in a criminal trial and
they're crying i i think sachi's
outsized role in the white house is
something worth discussing beyond the
points that you're making about her
misleading and false statements
it's almost as if she's presidential
you know they issued a statement uh from
jen sackey on
i don't know something had passed just
last week or something that they
objected to and it was a statement as if
the president had issued it it was
statement by white house secretary press
secretary jen sackey and i remember
thinking well this is odd it sounds
presidential
and uh to me her outsized role in this
administration is further indication
of the diminished
uh cognitive abilities of the president
of the united states it's clear come on
she is running yeah come on boy she is
running the show and certain and
certainly uh beyond
uh any normal press secretary donald
trump was except for joseph
donald trump was funny and he talked in
a funny way one of the one you know what
i absolutely love about trump is this
bit where he will say something
outrageous
and then when the press challenges him
he'll be like well that's what i was
told like like that like if that
absolves him of being wrong so it's like
i laugh at that i'm critical of it
donald trump will be like you know we've
got this new medication coming out and
they're like sir you know a question mr
president that is not correct you're
talking about an old report that's since
been debunked i was told this just a
moment ago that's what i was told and
it's it's funny because that's like his
defense
joe biden
is different like that's donald trump's
like cognitive faculties trying to
muster up something you know he can't
just come out and be like okay well i
was wrong about that because he's
because he's trump but at least he said
something we understand well they told
me that that's why i'm saying it joe
biden he says america can be described
in in in one word
i'm a from from an inheritance
and i was like
what what word was that
tim and then you've got you've got next
no-resistant batacaf care shouldn't i
shop at a pressure the dude's not even
speaking words i think you missed his
point you saying this country is
indescribable it's that feeling it gives
him it's just the emotions it's coming
out it's so overwhelming he can't speak
you know be funny like on the
teleprompter it actually said that and
it's like
when everybody makes fun of me gets sad
because he thought he made up a great
new word
well does that not sound like a snopes
like dude webster's going to start
adding this stuff to the dictionary like
a rock musician from the early 90s you
know on a sidebar judicial watch issue
we had caught uh saki lying about
biden's dog bites uh you know major was
running around by and he wasn't just
nipping at people because he was
startled he was shooting across the
driveway to attack people shooting
across 10 feet of room to go after
agents and biting the heck out of them
didn't he hurt biden himself like well
by the way supposedly
joe biden was bathing with showering
with his dog in the room
joe biden says he broke foot tripping
after shower when he pulled his dog's
tail yeah why was ridiculous in the
bathroom hold on why was the dog in the
back know but it's a german shepherd
they they are protective of love they're
going to be there he says the story to
be fair all right to be fair we got the
description originally from jill biden
it's not like jen it's not like jen sack
he was out there like the president uh
saw his dog and tried to grab his tail
after a shower like joe was like i saw
my dog man
i grabbed his tail a little rascal it's
like it's one of those
things like this it's hysterical
abiding quote no you guys should you
guys should look it up and listen it's
actually hysterical it's like one of my
it's one of the funniest things he said
that we overlooked the most funnily
accurate thing that joe biden has said
recently love it
you know but saki gets out there and she
says hey you know it was a minor dog
bite and the secret you know we just got
the emails secret service agents were
furious
they're you know look they're lucky they
didn't have to put the dog down it was
that crazy surprise they didn't man let
me read this he says quote what happened
was i got out of the shower actually can
you see that seamus yeah can you can you
joe biting that for us come on man
yeah yeah what happened was i i got out
of the shower
i got i got a dog and anyone who's been
around my house and nose
dropped little pup dropped a ball in
front of me
and for me to grab the ball
biden told cnn journalist jake tapper in
the first post election interview with
vice president-elect kamala harris and
i'm walking through this little alleyway
to get to the bedroom and i grab grab
the ball like this and he ran and i'm
joking running after him and grabbed his
tail and what happened is that he slid
on a throw rug and i tripped on the rug
he slid on
that's what happened oh man not a very
exciting story he said he was running
down an alleyway so yeah this hallway he
says he got i maybe i should animate
this one we animated
that story because we animated the corn
pop story and helped a lot of people
understand it better we just used his
narration uh but yeah he's basically
saying he like he got out of the shower
he got out of the shower and his dog had
a ball so he started chasing his dog
with him i just want you to imagine this
right come on so so let's be fair the
dog must not have been in the bathroom
he because it doesn't say that but so so
joe
is he wearing a towel or did he get out
of the shower i was picturing him with a
towel on pictures i hope he had a towel
on because well
originally i thought he climbed out of
the shower
naked he probably slipped in the shower
and broke his foot and now he's created
this stupid story and he's like and what
happened was which is a sign of a liar
when they buy time you know in their
normal conversation long time journalist
ron kessler reported that the secret
service complained about biden's
swimming habits as being
wildly inappropriate in the buff
yeah oh wait what gross
really it's in a book you can do a lot
with that one sheamus i know that that
could be nice
i'm sure you can find the audio of him
telling the story i remember looking for
it a while ago because i had the same
idea this story was pointed out to me
and i couldn't believe that i missed it
when it happened so i was searching for
the audio clip i i think i had trouble
finding it um it might have just been
something he said to a reporter that was
quoted in the press and wasn't actually
filmed the reason i think you all can
find it send it to me i think he's lying
about the story is because if he's going
to tell a story about how he's chasing
his dog down the hallway and pulled its
tail and broke his foot why would he
bring up the shower part of it it was
completely irrelevant to the story so
obviously it was part of the story
the bigger the story the bigger the lie
that's that's the old saying so uh
typically among kids when they're lying
they try to they try to explain every
possible thing when in reality uh you
know it's like how did you break your
foot i was playing the dog i fell
yeah that's it i was like i fell playing
with the dog but the reality is he's 76
and he's slept in the shower i mean
that's
that's my guess i don't know that i
don't know whether he's lying or because
honestly i one million percent believe
that this is something he would do do
you guys not think that joe biden would
like chase his dog
you want to know my favorite thing about
the story was the conspiracy theorists
who were who kept telling everybody when
when was this this was uh december 3rd
2020. the conspiracy theorists who are
who kept pushing you know the election
stuff said that he he didn't really
break his foot he's hiding the ankle
bracelet because oh what yeah no no joke
so that's what they were saying and my
favorite was when they started believing
that joe biden flipped and was now
helping trump and he was like it's just
great people look at a photo of biden
with a hurt foot and that's what they
think and i'm like dude he's an old man
he fell yeah that's funny another reason
i question is cause like you saw what to
do with fdr when he was getting polio is
like basically making him paralyzed they
hid that from people for like years i
believe i'm not sure exactly how long
but they didn't want people to know the
president wasn't doing well they'll hide
that there is no plan i keep on saying
there is no plan
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you